the issue you have is women like Emily
Rakowski you know marriage again I've
said this before marriage isn't marriage
anymore the average marriage is seven
years we have things like no fault
divorce leave if you're unhappy so what
does that mean marriage isn't marriage
anymore because there have been so many
marriages the course of history where
people have been very unhappy either the
man or the woman has been very unhappy
and they've been forced basically to
stay in a marriage it could have been an
abusive marriage could abusive marriage
and that would we have one life why
would you spend it with
someone problem we have with women like
women men tend to be better people than
us